nevermind the Nikola Tesla was probably
the smartest person to have ever have
lived never mind that 80% of all of your
technology is because of him
never mind that almost every single
electronic item or anything you have
that plugs in or charges is the direct
result of his works and achievements and
inventions never mind that he could
speak eight languages or that he had 700
patents from around the world or that
the electric motor your radio remote
controls lasers limitless free energy
potentially and the alternating current
are all a result of his works and yet
most people aren't even aware of him all
you hear about is Thomas Edison who
created the lightbulb as you're aware
and yet Thomas Edison was practically
[ __ ] without Tesla now hold on I know
that Thomas Edison was a brilliant man
however the foundation of most of his
inventions are because of Tesla's work
in fact are you aware the thomas edison
had promised 10,000 dollars to Tesla in
order to approve his DC current which he
was having issues with at the time and
in the process
Tesla end up inventing the AC current D
alternating current which is what we use
in anywhere in modern in the modern
world for electricity
it requires significantly less power to
be used and it's just brilliant and
Edison didn't like that because it
wasn't his invention so he refused to
pay Tesla his $10,000 and instead he
went on an aggressive marketing campaign
to try and convince the public and the
powers that be that the alternating
current was bad it would burn down
cities and every house in America and he
even went to the extent to kill an
electrocute an elephant dogs and horses
to try and prove his point that guy is a
sicko Edison can go screw himself like
for real
he's not who people think he was he was
a dirtbag a greedy money-hungry dirtbag
all that being said Edison failed in his
attempt because obviously Tesla's
invention of the AC current was so
superior that here it is today yet when
I mentioned limited limitless free
energy there is enough evidence that
suggests that Tesla had figured that out
when I say evidence I would say more of
fiying evidence rather than quantitative
but if you're not aware tests will
despite all of his achievements died
poor and shunned at the age of 86 and
when he died less than two days later
the United States government raided his
hotel room and took absolutely
everything out of it all of his works is
not everything and who knows what they
did with it they claimed that they gave
everything back to his family later on
in Europe but nobody knows for sure what
they took now with all this being said
and there's many other things I can
mention about him like x-rays or spark
plugs and everything else that is in our
lives today 10d credited at their root
because of the works of Tesla but I have
to stop there because I can keep going
on about that the most important
achievements that he had wasn't
necessarily the death ray that is
believed that he had created that his
works are probably the result now of
some incredible top-secret weapons of
mass destruction that have been utilized
or have been created I should say by the
United States government which a lot of
people are interested in people are
fascinated by what it was that Tesla had
figured out that was made the United
States government so eager to take his
stuff and obviously limitless free
energy is one of them because the powers
that be don't want limitless free energy
fact you only have to look at today on
how the biggest corporations on planet
earth have bought up almost all of the
water rights that they possibly can in
order to be able to charge mankind for
the most crucial element that we need or
thing that we need which is water so
never mind all that because I have a
theory that Tesla had discovered
something far more significant let's use
it as an example I'll be throwing some
quotes up here on the screen I'll read
some of them to you but feel free to
press pause in case I don't leave it up
on the screen long enough for you to
read it so but let's look at like this
well Tesla never went to work in his
laboratory or creating his inventions or
without what he did first I should say
is to develop the idea in his brain and
then he would go through every possible
thing that could go wrong with it any
opportunity for improvement and you'd
work it all out and simply just his
brain before putting any of it to
practical use or building any of the
technology and it was so successful for
him and what I'm suggesting here and as
I throw up some of these quotes is that
Tesla had discovered a way as we all
actually naturally are able to do we
just don't realize it
to essentially be dialed in to the
universal energies that essentially
thoughts that comes to us you ever
wonder where those come from I have to
say that some of the most brilliant
ideas I've ever had in my life or
life-changing ideas that were for the
better
seemingly came out of nowhere and I
can't explain it you only have to look
at various people successful songs ever
written the most amazing works of art
other inventions the most successful
CEOs talk about this stuff as well it's
all about intuition that essentially if
you put in a will to something it will
materialize make no mistake we as humans
are creators now I'm going to pull back
a little bit on this conversation and
save it for another video where I could
talk about the occult or universal
energies and that essentially I'm
convinced that every one of us has a
divine nature to us now hold on I'm not
talking religion here I'm talking about
the source of all things and how you can
utilize your powers in my take powers
like don't forget you are one dirt and
now you're a living breathing thing that
survives by eating things that grow on
the ground that were once dirt and yet
you'll be dirt again but in the middle
of all that you are a people of
experiencing love and how do you explain
love or laughter where do those things
fit in for the strongest survive I'm
convinced I believe in a divineness to
everything I just don't see it in the
same ways that most organized religions
explain it because they're all mating so
much truth and they lots of religions
being made now I'm not saying everything
you read in the Bible of ran or anywhere
else isn't true I think there's a lot of
truth to those two major religions but
what I'm saying here is that there are
more truths out there that we haven't
seemingly discovered yet I'll say I'll
leave it at that I'll save more of this
for another video but now let me get on
to these quotes they'll kind of paint
you a picture of where I'm going with
this
for example Tesla said but instinct is
something which transcends knowledge we
have undoubtedly certain finer fibers
that enable us to perceive truth when
logical deductions or any other willful
effort of the brain is fetal and this is
part of the reason why his works were
suppressed is that I'm convinced the
powers that be do understand that
intuitions are real thing and they don't
want everyone to know that they want the
masses to be essentially just sheep that
fall in line and don't think for
themselves and lack creativity that way
the powers that be
the Illuminati or whatever you want to
call them can just maximize the
experience of their earthly existence if
you want to find the secrets of the
universe think in terms of energy
frequency and vibration
guys this is validated as our research
and technological capabilities allowed
scientists modern-day scientists to
learn about atoms that atoms make up
everything whether it be a rock or a pen
this iPad everything nothing solid
everything's made up of the finest
things the smallest things that we know
of in the universe which are atoms which
have a nucleus and electron and
seemingly when you have an object like a
rock what you're not aware of what your
human eyes don't show you is that most
of that rock is actually hollow when we
perceive as being completely solid isn't
actually the case as discovered on the
atomic level so everything is an atom
everything is made up of an energy we
don't necessarily understand how it
works just like say consciousness like
scientists agree that consciousness is a
form of energy they don't understand how
it works but they all agree that well
energy is something that cannot be
created or destroyed only transformed
which is another reason why I buy into
our divineness and that there's a lot of
things going on behind the scenes that
are the veil of the human eyes don't
allow us to see I mean look here's
another quote the gift of mental power
comes from God divine being and if we
concentrate our minds on that truth we
become in tune with this great power now
I'm under the impression that Tesla
wasn't actually a religious person but
yet he did believe that there was some
sort of force out there that allowed us
to connect to everything and get us to
where we are today in developing that we
have even Einstein talked about this
people will try and tell you oh yeah
Einstein was the atheist no he wasn't he
wasn't religious but he talked about
intuition as well and his most famous
quotes on that have been suppressed in
fact at the beginning of this video I
said you know Tesla being one of the
smartest people ever and a lot of people
will disagree but no no no I'm sign of
course as a smartest person ever well
look at what Einstein said about Tesla
he wasn't kidding he really truly
believed that Tesla was the smartest
person in existence yet in school I
don't remember learning about Tesla even
once never ever did I learn about Tesla
in school you have to start adding up
why is that and yet he was able to
develop some of the most significant and
important
mentions in the history of the world all
by just thinking things up if you think
this is because he was smart unless they
had a high IQ guys that's not what it is
think about how many modern scientists
out there don't develop crap and think
about it Tesla actually spoke about this
in fact take this quote for example
today's scientists have substituted
mathematics for experiments and they
wander off through equation after
equation and eventually build a
structure which has no relation to
reality he's not kidding
most of the world's smartest people
today are not putting their genius to
practical use so the same reason why
they can't create incredible inventions
the way Tesla did despite not having the
internet and all kinds of other
resources
he used his imagination Alexander Graham
Bell talked about this
Einstein talked about this many many
others some of the most significant
inventors of all time have spoken about
this like I said CEOs have spoken about
this even coddled Trump has spoken about
this and even if you don't like him give
him some credit we're talking about
someone who's been enormous ly
successful in his life became the
president United States despite all the
odds against them and he has talked
about that everything changed in his
life once he started listening to his
instincts instincts and intuition is
real guys and that's the important
message behind this video Tesla was
dialed in he figured that out so I hope
that this video helps open your mind to
see that look if you trust Tesla trust
your intuition it's that first feeling
or thought that comes to you your
thoughts everything else like your brain
the human brain will screw you over but
start researching intuition it's a real
thing there are some sort of energies
out there that allow us to access
information and it is well look
something big is happening behind the
scenes and I'm convinced of it so I'm
going to close up there I'm Jimmy this
is bright insight like and subscribe
help me spread the message take care
everybody